Jack Hand im Nordosten von Indien hier
Graben Rena und ihr Mann nach einem
Rohstoff den die deutsche Industrie
dringend braucht Mika auch Glimmer
genannt weil es so schön glitzert
abgebaut wird das Mineral unter der Erde
ohne große Maschinen sondern von Hand
bei bis zu 45 Grad Celsius ich komme
fast jeden Tag hierher nur Samstags ruhe
ich mich etwas aus
diese Region ist eine der ärmsten
Indiens der Abbau von Mika ist in Jack
Hand illegal trotzdem wird die Mika für
die ganze Welt aus der Erde geholt
wir steigen nicht zu tief ab unten in
den Minen ist es gefährlich manchmal
stürzen sie ein
tausende andere gehen das Risiko ein
regelmäßig sterben Menschen auch die
Kleinsten müssen ran 30.000 Kinder in
den Minen schätzen Hilfsorganisationen
keine Ahnung was damit passiert wir
schaffen das Mika nur und verkaufen es
an die Zwischenhändler damit wir uns was
zu essen kaufen können
heute haben Rena und ihr Mann 20
Kilogramm Mika gesammelt dafür bekommen
sie umgerechnet 2,50 €. sie leben
unterhalb der Armutsgrenze
Deutschland ist der drittgrößte Mika
Importeur der Welt viele Industrien
benötigen das Mineral für Elektrogeräte
wie Smartphones und Akkus weil es
isoliert weil es glitzert steckt es auch
in Farben und Lacken und in
Kosmetikprodukten wie schminke Lipgloss
und Nagellack
Berlin um Kinderarbeit zu verhindern und
halbwegs faire Löhne zu sichern hatte
schon die Regierung Merkel ein
lieferkettengesetz präsentiert nach
langem Streit Gerd Müller damals
Entwicklungsminister wollte ein scharfes
Gesetz der damalige Wirtschaftsminister
Altmaier verhinderte das
[Musik]
Armin Paasch hat das gezelle um das
lieferkettengesetz beobachtet für ihn
eine beispiellose verhinderungskampagne
leider haben sich Wirtschaftsminister
Altmaier und auch Kanzlerin Merkel voll
vor den Karren der Wirtschaftslobby
spannen lassen sie haben einem
lieferkettengesetz erst dann zugestimmt
nachdem sie es massiv verbessert hatten
geplant war es für Unternehmen ab 250
Beschäftigte nun gilt es vorerst ab 3000
ursprünglich hätten Unternehmen ihre
gesamte Lieferkette im Blick haben
müssen bis zum Miene es wurde begrenzt
auf den ersten Zulieferern
geplant war eine zivilrechtliche Haftung
Opfer von Menschenrechtsverletzungen
hätten vor deutschen Gerichten auf
Schadensersatzklagen können das wurde
komplett gestrichen
zurück in Indien wir dürfen Rena nach
Hause begleiten ihre vier Kinder dürfen
zur Schule gehen müssen nicht in den
Minen arbeiten auch wenn das bedeutet
dass die Familie weniger Geld hat ohne
Mika geht es nicht
das Mika muss eine Woche trocknen dann
kann ich es an einen Händler verkaufen
wem verkaufst du es
es kommt immer jemand anders um es
abzuholen nicht immer der gleiche
[Musik]
weil der Abbau illegal ist kommen die
Zwischenhändler nur nachts
wir fahren in die Stadt geridi
Hauptumschlagplatz von Mika in der
Region viele internationale Exporteure
haben sich hier niedergelassen denn nur
der Abbau von Mika ist illegal der
Handel damit nicht
wir wollen mit Ihnen sprechen aber
niemand mit uns Öffentlichkeit schädigt
das Geschäft
schließlich erklärt sich ein
Zwischenhändler bereit seinen Namen
sollen wir nicht nennen vom deutschen
lieferkettengesetz bis er nichts
nein wir haben davon nichts gehört die
internationalen Exporteure erzählen uns
auch nichts wie sollten wir also auch
davon wissen
der Händler bestätigt uns sein Mika
komme aus jakannt dem Bundesstaat in dem
Menschen Verena Mika illegal aus dem
Boden kratzen
Amerika Deutschland Frankreich Russland
Tschechien Polen Ungarn Japan unser Mika
geht überall hin
frontal liegen Exportdaten vor sie
zeigen zu den größten Importeuren
Deutschlands gehört der Pharmariese Merk
und Merck kauft sein Mika in jakannt
allein im Jahr 2021 waren es
4.500 Tonnen merk liefert Glimmer an
weitere Hersteller europaweit
auf seiner Website schreibt das
Unternehmen
wir beziehen den Rohstoff nur wenn er
aus formellen Arbeitsumgebungen stammt
nur so können wir kontrollieren ob
unsere Standards eingehalten werden etwa
das Verbot von Kinderarbeit
Barbara Küppers von tereson forscht zu
den Abbaubedingungen von Mika viele Male
war sie vor Ort das ist Mika sieht schön
aus glitzert wie hoch ist die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass da die
Menschenrechtsverletzungen verstecken 99
Prozent warum weil das eben illegal ist
Korruption des unters Dach und da vor
Ort niemanden Interesse hat dass man das
rausfindet es ist Stand heute nicht
möglich die ganze Lieferkette von Mika
nachzuverfolgen und nachzuvollziehen
kommt das Mika konkret aus einer Grube
wo Kinder mitarbeiten oder nicht geht
nicht auf Anfrage schreibt merk Zitat
jegliche Form von Kinderarbeit lehnen
wir strikt ab
dazu habe der Konzern ein umfassendes
System von Kontrollmechanismen
implementiert weiter heißt es der
Verzicht auf Zwischenhändler die enge
Zusammenarbeit mit wenigen Lieferanten
und die internen sowie externen
Kontrollen helfen uns die sozialen
Standards durchzusetzen
[Musik]
Brüssel aktuell streitet das Europäische
Parlament um ein eigenes
lieferkettengesetz der Entwurf ist so
weitreichend wie das deutsche Gesetz
bevor es verbessert wurde
[Musik]
es soll wieder für Unternehmen ab 250
Beschäftigte gelten die Sorgfaltspflicht
soll entlang der gesamten
Wertschöpfungskette gelten nicht auf den
ersten Zulieferer begrenzt und die
zivilrechtliche Haftung ist wieder
vorgesehen betroffene können dann doch
vor europäischen Gerichten auf
Schadensersatz klagen
Wirtschaftsverbände sind aufgeschreckt
und machen wieder Druck diesmal in
Brüssel und treffen auf Verständnis bei
der Union Markus Ferber sitzt für die
CSU im EU-Parlament er teilt die Kritik
deutscher Unternehmen
wir werden viele Lieferbeziehungen in
kritische Regionen zu Ende bringen das
heißt am Ende wird es den Menschen dort
nicht besser gehen wer also meint über
das lieferkettengesetz würde sich der
Situation der Menschen in anderen Teilen
dieser Erde verbessern der belügt sich
selbst
Berlin auch die ampelregierung versucht
das EU-Gesetz abzuschwächen nach
Recherchen von Korrektiv und frontal ist
es vor allem die FDP
Bundesjustizminister Marco Buschmann
will die sogenannte Safe harbor-regel im
Gesetz festschreiben lassen das hätte
weitreichende Folgen
für indische schörfer würde es sehr viel
schwieriger Schadensersatz von einem
deutschen Unternehmen
einzuklagen dass die Menschenrechte dort
verletzt hat der Schürfer müsste nämlich
belegen dass das Unternehmen vorsätzlich
oder grob fahrlässig gehandelt hat das
ist aber ohne Einsicht in die Akten
diese Unternehmen quasi unmöglich
interne Dokumente zeigen die FDP hat
sich in der Ampel durchgesetzt die
Bundesregierung besteht in Brüssel auf
einer Haftungsbeschränkung
zwingend erforderlich Deutschland wird
einem Text nur zustimmen der diese
Bedingung erfüllt
Amin Paasch und die Initiative
lieferkettengesetz haben der
Bundesregierung eine Petition überreicht
mit 90.000 Unterschriften ihre Forderung
verbessern statt verwässern die FDP
fordert jetzt rote Linien für ganz
Europa es kann nicht sein dass eine
Partei die im Moment noch 5%
Unterstützung in der deutschen
Bevölkerung hat ganz Europa praktisch
die Pistole auf die Brust setzt das FDP
geführte Justizministerium teilt mit die
Bundesregierung unterstütze ein
lieferkettengesetz unter der Bedingung
dass es Zitat kleinere und mittlere
Unternehmen nicht überfordert
wenn FDP und Lobbyisten sich in Brüssel
durchsetzen wird sich für Räder und ihre
Kinder nichts ändern
alles ist so teuer geworden wie soll man
von so wenig Geld leben ich muss doch
meine Kinder ernähren
nach dem glitzernden Stoff den die Welt
so begehrt